if you think about like pop smoke like
he wouldn't even know it was like a kid
you saw where he was at on instagram so
kids from the hood and they rolled up on
them and like
that could happen to anybody yeah sure
you know that it came with my
and it came with my airbnb before it
came with whatever
you were there recently nope i want that
though so saying just i had just left
like i had just left uh that morning
and i just had level randomly too i just
like i had just got up cause i posted
like two more days
but uh i had just lived
when i got up in the morning i was like
i'm gonna go home be with my kids before
i
go to africa i just wanted to see my
kids i just got out that morning just
booked the flight and did
and uh i had booked a flight of dip and
uh
so you left and then right after you
left some people ran up in the airbnb
you were at
yeah was anybody there yeah uh my
manager my artist was there
did they get robbed or what yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh wow they're they're good
though
yeah they're great they're great that's
great like that's crazy because you
never know how they could have found out
you were there
yeah they could you know what else too
we were just we we was hot born i ain't
gonna lie we was high born we were deaf
for like
weeks you know saying doing the la
experience having house parties
[ __ ] like that just just just
not maybe not moving the smartest yeah
not moving the spot but you know we had
security stuff over there but they came
in like two of them
it don't matter yeah it don't matter
yeah yeah that's crazy so
so obviously you learned from that yeah
because i feel like it could have been
bad man
yeah like i feel like if i if i would
tell like you know said
knowing me i probably probably i
wouldn't even say like i'm just rambling
but i don't know like how i sleep you
feel me
it probably would have been a shootout
but you never know like who would have
won that shootout you know what i'm
saying because i
sleep like that was out here yeah yeah
yeah
so yeah you know what's crazy too with
these airbnbs is like
everybody using the same the same ones
so all you got to see is one little
sliver on someone's story yeah
and if you know you know where that one
is because every rapper
every artist there's only a certain
amount of airbnbs in the hills
and like yeah baby [ __ ] that's that's
crazy
thank god you will saw your kids you
know what i'm saying yeah